okay this is this is a sort of a
complicated thing to discuss but
at some point we meaning the united
states collectively
we are going to owe the world an
explanation
and an apology and i don't mean just
generally for donald trump but i'm
talking more broadly because of our
failure on coronavirus i'm talking
broadly because of our failure to
continue leading on climate change i'm
talking about our failure
really to just hold back the advancement
of humanity
instead regressing dramatically over the
last three and a half years and maybe
for another four
now to set the stage accurately
i'm not pretending that the united
states nor the world were
idyllic panaceas during the era of
barack obama that would be
revisionist history that would be wrong
that's certainly not the point of this
segment to pretend things were just
perfect
until donald trump became president but
as an example
we were at least an important part of
thinking about how to deal with climate
change when barack obama was president
of the united states we hadn't figured
it out certainly
but we were serious participants in the
conversation the obama administration
understood
the us is disproportionately relative to
our population a big polluter
a big emitter of of of pollution and
emissions
and we were taking it seriously not
enough was done
we had not figured it out but our role
was at least
respectable around the world our role
now on climate change
has gone from respectable to not
respectable
to having no role whatsoever because
we're actually a huge part of the
problem as donald trump has
claimed that climate change is a hoax
created by china propped up oil and gas
while loosening car emission standards
and the world has rightly
started either ignoring us in these
important climate change conversations
they're actually pointing out that we're
a huge part of the problem
on coronavirus of course this
administration has proven that it still
matters who is president we have seen
arguably one of the worst responses in
the world to the pandemic i don't know
how much time i have to spend on that
today since we've covered it almost
daily for months
but suffice it to say almost any
functioning adult
would have said i don't need to lead
this let's defer to the doctors and we'd
be better off right we didn't need
anything outlandish to better handle
coronavirus than the way this
administration has handled it we just
needed some adult to say
oh i'm not an expert in this but i know
who is
let's let's let's allow them to lead the
way
we've talked about voting trump out as
only being
the first step and that's true from a
policy standpoint
but it's also true from the standpoint
of defeating trumpism
defeating trump will not instantly end
trumpism if donald trump loses in
november and leaves the oval office in
january
but there's another area in which
defeating donald trump is only the first
step which is
starting to rebuild our alliances around
the world
starting to recover some semblance of
respect from our historical allies and
from the people of this planet
so this is not about being ashamed of
the country
even though certainly you wouldn't be
wrong to feel that right now as we have
become a laughingstock
this is not about punishing trump
supporters
although there's no doubt that they are
responsible for the fact that this
president was elected
this is about realizing that part of
being respected again
and rebuilding those relationships is
going to be
an implicit apology some kind of
explanation
as to our commitment to fixing the
disaster that the united states has been
globally during the time of donald trump
now if donald trump were to win in
november the case for such an apology
and an explanation and a rehabilitation
of our reputation becomes much more
difficult
almost 63 million people voted for
donald trump in 2016.
the reality is some number close to that
or even more are going to vote for him
again
in 2020. the question of course is going
to be
do enough additional people vote for joe
biden
such that donald trump loses in the
electoral college now in the next
segment i'm going to talk about the
reality that
any view that thinks biden's got this is
not based in fact and i'm going to go
into detail about that after the break
but let's imagine even if donald trump
is defeated in november
there will still be the inconvenient and
humiliating reality
that somewhere between probably 60 and
65 million americans in all likelihood
will have seen the last four years of
trump
and the disaster that it's been and they
will say i'm voting
for another four and they will vote for
donald trump a second time
so how do we get out of this removing
donald trump is only going to be step
0.1 in the process the world deserves
answers
the world deserves an explanation we owe
it to the world
and an explanation about how we will not
allow the country to be hijacked by the
non-thinking ideas of the
60 plus million people who even if trump
loses in november
will have voted for another four years
so what is the path forward i actually
don't have the answers i want to hear
from you
i'm on twitter at d pacman we'll take a
break
and we'll follow up about this either
tomorrow or next week
one of our sponsors is cuts clothing and
they're giving you
15 off of everything they offer
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s cuts clothing has
completely changed the game when it
comes to
solid color t-shirts obviously solid
color
t-shirts are an important staple in any
wardrobe which is all the more reason
that you should be wearing t-shirts that
you actually love
it really does impact your day to day
you've got your typical poorly made
t-shirt it's scratchy
it shrinks the neck becomes all floppy
the color fades it all starts to warp
over time
none of that happens with cuts clothing
as soon as i first put on a t-shirt from
cuts clothing
i could immediately tell the difference
between this
and the other poorly made shirts that
i've owned in the past and it's really a
very noticeable level of quality and
comfort and style
which i believe will change how you
think about t-shirts
go check out what they offer they also
have this new line of polo shirts
it's really more comfortable than any
polo shirt i've ever worn
cuts clothing will be a total game
changer when it comes to
t-shirts they're really the only t-shirt
worth buying
and now they've got the polos and you'll
get 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s